[Música]
oi gente
- eu tenho 11 anos e hoje eu gostaria de
falar com vocês sobre o nosso super
atual guerra
você sabe quantos possivelmente diante
de uma terceira guerra mundial só como
esse é um assunto muito abrangente e
gostaria de falar especificamente sobre
a guerra das coréias e o seu impacto no
mundo atual
já deve ter visto as seguintes notícias
na mídia na televisão no jornal mas para
compreendermos o que elas falam e o que
está acontecendo agora quero voltar no
tempo entender um pouco da história tudo
começou em 1910 quando a península da
coréia ficou sob domínio do império
japonês
este domingo era tão intenso que
japoneses bilhão de falar coreano e ter
nomes coreanos para matar a cultura
coreana e impor japonesa após a segunda
guerra mundial o japão perdeu o domínio
sobre pneus ou porém a união soviética
só concordou se pudessem influência em
uma parte seria a parte norte e os
estados unidos com medo então não
cumprir o acordo influenciou a parte sul
até que em 1948 iniciou se a guerra fria
cada país defendeu a sua parte houveram
muitas invasões no território inimigo e
alternadamente o sul quase dominou norte
eo norte quase dominou o sul até que a
china decidiu intervir quando começou a
lançar seu exército os dois lados sabiam
que não poderiam vencer então em 1953
assinaram um armistício
aproximadamente 4 milhões de pessoas
morreram sendo que a maioria é um
serviço um absurdo né
e com o fim da guerra as duas coreias
permanecem divididas e os conflitos
geopolíticos continuam hoje em dia a
coreia do norte segue no sistema no
regime comunista ea coreia do sul no
sistema capitalista e meio governos
muito diferentes as duas coreias tiveram
economias muito parecidas até mais ou
menos a década de 70
mas então a qual a solução é investir
ela emitiu em desenvolvimento tecnologia
saúde educação e com isso começou a
crescer enquanto a coréia do norte foi
acionada
vamos falar um pouco sobre a diferença
das coreias vocês saibam que é isso é
uma foto tirada satélite à noite para
comprovar o que eu disse antes a coreia
do sul está totalmente iluminada
mostrando-se otto em desenvolvimento
sobre a coreia do norte que está pouco
iluminada puxar um pouco de governo até
hoje as creches
ae a coreia do norte e apenas três
líderes enquanto a coreia do sul 12
líderes
isso é para vocês verem a dinastia
versus a democracia aqui é para vocês
vêem como a coreia do norte investiu no
seu armamento
no total a tem um milhão cento e noventa
mil militares na ativa enquanto a coreia
do sul 130 mil
aqui tem algumas informações que eu
gostaria de compartilhar com vocês por
ano a coreia do norte ganha 952 milhões
de dólares com exportações em brinquedos
de carvão enquanto a coreia do sul
aproximadamente 63 bilhões de dólares 1
milhões são bilhões de dólares em placas
de circuito e poucas distrações na
coréia nós são pavimentadas como é que
vocês conseguem imaginar o país somente
focando em seu regulamento e
interessante ter pouquíssimas teles
fomentadas outra coisa mesmo 1 a mesma
genética os norte-coreanos o mais baixo
e gente sério que hoje em dia consegue
viver sem celular
aproximadamente 3 milhões de pessoas na
coreia do norte têm celular
isso parece muito não parece mas se você
contar com toda sua população é muito
pouco e os sul-coreanos de ver mais os
sul-coreanos vivem em média 85 anos
enquanto os norte-coreanos 70 o que você
consegue fazer em 15 anos de vida
agora vamos pensar 12 todas essas
ameaças iniciais no sócio porque john
vou levar e vou levar em algum lugar na
minha opinião está causando medo e
terror os países vizinhos como coréia e
japão
a insegurança a todos para uma guerra
que nós todos sabemos que vai levar a
lugar nenhum e você o que acha sobre
isso porque sozinho não consigo
eu preciso da ajuda de vocês para
alertar todo mundo que nós e as próximas
gerações
visamos um mundo pacífico sem guerras
muito obrigado pela sua atenção
[Aplausos]